[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres menü welches
ihr zum beispiel zu weihnachten oder
auch zu anderen besonderen anlässen
zubereiten können ich werde nämlich das
perfekte rib eye steak machen und dazu
gibt's einen salat mit ruccola und
feldsalat und ich habe noch einen
kartoffel katar dabei und ich zeige euch
jetzt mal gleich wie man das perfekte
steak macht krieg stand danach zum essen
alles um das perfekte steak zuzubereiten
benötigt man natürlich auch ein
perfektes fleischstück ich habe zählen
ua bei steak man kann auch andere code
dazu sagen das eine ist die französische
bezeichnung das andere die amerikanische
und zwar ist das fleisch aus dem
zwischen rippen stück und ganz besonders
an fleisch ist eben der volle geschmack
das heißt es hat ein sehr intensives
aroma und es ist nicht trocken das heißt
ich habe hier im fleisch dieses
intramuskuläre fed also hier über all
diese kleinen weißen fettflecken wir
hier gut sehen könnt dadurch wird das
fleisch zart und eben auch nicht trocken
und bei rib eye steak ist ganz besonders
hier im innern dieser fed kern den muss
man nicht mit essen aber bei der
zubereitung hilft er einfach super mit
dass es eben schon sagt bleibt und auch
schön saftig und ich hab es rib eye
steak gewählt denn ihr müsst euch jetzt
vorstellen wenn man sich den rücken der
kuh so vorstellt hat man unten
das roastbeef zu einem drittel dann ein
drittel rib eye steak oder eben
entrecote und oben die hochkippe und je
höher man geht also am rücken des der
kuh umso intensiver wetter geschmack
aber umso geringer wird auch das fleisch
und zum steak braten schrecklichsten
sweep perfekt deswegen habe ich das
gewählt dass ich auch hier richtig schön
dick und reicht auch später wirklich so
also die größe jetzt für zwei bis drei
personen je nachdem was man eben auch
dazu macht also für murat und mich ist
das perfekte steak sodass es medium ist
im innern das heißt die kerntemperatur
hat so zwischen 56 und 58 grad wenn man
es eher business english x ray medium
dann sind es 54 56 grad meine mama und
mein papa würden so gar nicht essen die
würden das durch essen und würden das
fleisch im prinzip packte schon tot war
ich zeige euch jetzt wie man das steak
wirklich medium hinbekommt und zwar gibt
es da verschiedene techniken interesse
und super toller küchenchef sein
seid einfach mega viel erfahrung und
kann das alles ohne jegliche geräte oder
ihr müsst einfach die perfekten tipps
und tricks haben also das geheimnis ist
dass man das fleisch wirklich rückwärts
guard das heißt man bringt erst auf die
kerntemperatur von 6 50 bis 58 grad und
bretz danach an um dann die tollen
röstaromen zu erhalten
das ganze könnte jetzt entweder im
backofen machen zum beispiel mit einem
kerntemperatur messer
da müsst ihr dann entweder dabei bleiben
oder ihr habt ihn kennt raumtemperatur
messer mit seinem feature daran habe ich
erfahren dass es sowas auch gibt ich
werde es heute etwas einfacher machen
und wer das zu wigan sowie garen heißt
unter vakuumgaren und das macht man mit
hilfe von vakuumbeutel also mit so
kunststoffbeutel und einem vakuum ihr
gerät und da gibt es natürlich ganz
spezielle geräte jetzt für den
profibereich und ich habe hier einst für
den hausgebrauch das ist wirklich super
einfach und auch wirklich freizeit muss
ich dazu sagen ich habe zählt die beutel
und auch das gerät von gvo genommen und
habe jetzt hier so ein paar
kunststoffbeutel mit dabei kleine und
große und der vorteil vom vakuumgaren
also von sweet daran ist dass ich jetzt
in den beutel nicht nur das fleisch
reinpacken kann sondern das ganze auch
ein bisschen aromatisieren kann mit
verschiedenen kräutern
das heißt ich habe hier noch etwas
rosmarin rosmarinzweig und ein bisschen
thymian
jetzt nehme ich die beutel oder einen
beutel macht ihn auf und die beute sind
jetzt nicht nur fürs zumutbaren muss
sondern man kann darin lebensmittel auch
haltbar machen und zum beispiel auch gut
einfrieren
damit man kein gefrierbrand bekommt ich
hab das zu leisten hier auch schon mit
salami gemacht mit wurst und käse das
kann man auch ganz gut verpacken und im
kühlschrank lagern
das sind die lebensmittel nämlich etwas
länger haltbar
so sind im innern so ein bisschen
griffen jetzt lege ich jetzt fleisch
rein da jetzt einfach drauf achten
gerade das eis trägt nicht so
auseinander fällt
man kann es auch vorher mit einem
küchengarn ein bisschen zusammen bin und
oder markus einfache bitte aufpassen
hier kommen jetzt die kräuter noch
mitteilen
und die gehen dann später den geschmack
und das aroma schön ab zum verschließen
gibt sie einen clip damit kann ich den
leuten zu ziehen
[Applaus]
hier habe ich auch ganz viel luft drin
und die luft muss jetzt raus und das
geht jetzt mit dem bakom ihrer hier oben
ist ein blauer punkt da setzt man ihn an
und jetzt müsst ihr nur ein paar mal
pumpen und sie dann auch gleich wie hier
die luft entweicht
[Musik]
ihr seht ihr das fleisch perfekt
eingepackt und ich habe hier keine luft
mehr mit tritten und jetzt zeige ich
euch wie man das ganze so weit gehen
kann
für das perfekte steak habe ich jetzt
schon zwei punkte abgearbeitet das heißt
ich habe ein gutes fleisch
ich habe schon ein vakuumiert und jetzt
fehlt noch der dritte teil und zwar
brauche ich jetzt natürlich auch im
gerät was erhitzen kann ich mache das
jetzt in der kenwood cooking chef die
kann ich ja erhitzen bis 140 grad und
das ganze auch auf zwei grad genau das
heißt ich kann hier drin und warmes
wasserbad machen mit 56 bis 58 grad und
darin kann das fleisch sozusagen auf die
56 bis 58 grad kommen
ich werdet ihr damit ein bisschen
schneller geht schon mal heißes wasser
einfüllen und falls ihr jetzt keine
kenwood cooking chef habt müsst ihr
natürlich ein anderes gerät haben was
ihr eben gut ersetzen könnte und wo ihr
die temperatur eben auch regeln und
kontrollieren können
[Musik]
jetzt stelle ich das wasser hier ein und
stellt das gerät auch gleich auf 60 grad
und erstmal damit dass jetzt einfach ein
bisschen schneller auch geht hier oben
kann ich die temperatur kontrollieren
und jetzt ist es so jetzt muss er das
stück fleisch auf temperatur kommen ganz
wichtig ist dass es fleisch nicht aus
dem kühlschrank heraus direkt
weiterverarbeitet wird das heißt wenn
jetzt dieses rib eye steak habe liegt
vorher raus aus dem kühlschrank damit
auf zimmertemperatur kommt und dann kann
es weiterverarbeitet werden
ich schalte jetzt kurz die maschine
auf 60
kontrolliere hier die temperatur und ich
habe aber auch noch mal extra ein
thermometer mit dabei was ich gleich mit
ins wasserbad lege um es einfach
wirklich zu kontrollieren
und ganz wichtig ist falls jetzt ihr
dieses rib eye steak so zubereiten
möchte das dauert so etwa 30 35 45
minuten bis es auf keinen temperatur
kommt aber es ist auch gar nicht schlimm
wenn sie mal ein bisschen länger drin
bleibt denn so habt ihr auch immer den
vorteil dass er es gut vorbereiten könnt
und wenn dann eure gäste kommen könnte
es aus dem wasserbad herausnehmen und
dann eben nur noch anbraten und
servieren
bei kalbfleisch müsst ihr darauf achten
dass darf nicht länger als zwei stunden
ebenso wieder drin bleiben was dann
später einfach matschig wird jetzt gebe
ich das thermometer noch mit reinen
kapieren schwimmt thermometer und damit
kann ich die hitze einfach noch mal
kontrollieren
und jetzt kommt das fleisch mit rein und
das fleisch ist jetzt auf
zimmertemperatur das heißt es wasser ist
eher wärmer als das fleisch deswegen
lass uns jetzt erstmal auf 60 damit das
wasser nicht so schnell unterkühlt und
kontrolliert einfach bis die temperatur
von 56 50 grad wieder erreicht ist und
hier muss jetzt noch der ecke mit drauf
damit die hitze die ganze zeit über
konstant bleibt
während das steak jetzt auf die
kerntemperatur kommt kann ich jetzt
schon mal die beilage zubereiten
bei mir geht es heute ganz klassisch
einfach ein kartoffelgratin denn das
fleisch schmeckt ja schon gut und da
haben eine richtig schöne bodenständige
beilage dies sehr gut schmeckt und die
man auch gut vorbereiten kann
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten für 4
personen ich brauche 500 gramm geschälte
kartoffeln hier habe ich 100 milliliter
sahne und 150 milliliter milch einen
rosmarinzweig eindruck zählt drei
viertel teelöffel salz pfeffer etwas
muskatnuss und einem käse zum überbacken
ich nehme da gerne einen kaffee käse ich
nehme jetzt zuerst einmal die kartoffeln
die habe ich ja schon gezählt das waren
ungefähr 650 gramm komplett gewicht und
wenn die schale wegfällt sind etwa 500
gramm
da die jetzt sehr groß sind werde ich
die halbieren und dann fein hobeln
das könnte jetzt entweder mit seiner
hose machen ich mache das jetzt kurz
hier oben muss er kurz ausschalten und
habt ihr diese dünne scheibe drin und da
geht es auch ganz schnell das piepst
jetzt gleich weil ich unten jetzt noch
die temperatur drauf habe die lasse ich
jetzt aber drauf
das gerät funktioniert aber trotzdem da
ich jetzt hier nicht über 60 grad bin
weil da hat man ansonsten so einer hitze
funktion als er seine schutzfunktion in
der maschine
aber weil ich unter 60 grad bin kann ich
jetzt trotzdem auf höchster stufe gehen
[Musik]
und ich nehme jetzt die kartoffeln und
habe hier einen topf denn ich mache
immer ganz gerne so dass ich das
kartoffel katar kurz einmal im topf
vorher aufkochen lassen
so verbindet sich alles ganz schön und
gab dann im ofen auch sehr gleichmäßig
durch kommen die flüssigkeiten in den
topf also sahne und milch
ihr könnt auch im prinzip nur milch
verwenden aber mit seiner witzigen
cremiger den knoblauch freilich feinen
dazu
[Musik]
jetzt noch mit muskatnuss abschmecken
und etwas pech dann die kartoffeln mit
rein kann ich denn herz schon mal auf
mittel hoher hitze stellen
jetzt gebe ich noch rosmarinnadeln
nation die passen immer perfekt zu den
kartoffeln
[Musik]
und die mischung lasse ich jetzt bei
mittlerer hitze einmal kurz aufkochen
für etwa zwei bis drei minuten und dann
ist die schon fertig und bereit für den
ofen
[Musik]
das kartoffel körperfülle ich jetzt in
meine gusseisen fans hinein
ihr könnt es natürlich auch in der
normalen auflaufform machen aber so
sitzt ziemlich hübsch aus und so hat
jeder einzelne gast die einzelnen
aktionen die fette ich vorher mit etwas
sonnenblumenöl
[Musik]
da fühle ich jetzt die kartoffeln rein
da gebe ich jetzt noch den geriebenen
käse drauf und bei dem käse ist so
derzeit läuft richtig schön im ofen und
deswegen mag ich den ganz gerne
und den bekommt er im prinzip im
supermarkt oder auch im türkischen
[Musik]
und so kam das kartoffelgratin jetzt in
den verwaisten backofen bei 200 grad
ober unterhitze für etwa 20 minuten bis
die oberfläche schön goldbraun ist
[Musik]
das kartoffelgratin ist jetzt fertig und
auch des fleisches fertig werd ichs
herausnehmen bezieht man auch schön die
farbe hat sich verändert die konsistenz
hat sich verändert es nämlich aus dem
beutel heraus und kann jetzt hier
inzwischen schon mal meine pfanne
erhitzen und zwar wenn ich das fleisch
in der eisen pfanne anbraten heißen
pfanne deswegen weil ich die sehr hoch
erhitzen kann und ich kann dann das
fleisch wirklich von beiden seiten ganz
scharf ganz heiß anbraten
wenn ich jetzt erst auf mittel hoher see
zu stellen
pfannen und töpfe immer erst noch mittel
hohe hitze und dann langsam hochschalten
und ein stück butter schmalz mit rein
damit die pfanne nicht alleine erhitzt
wird damit sie nicht überhitzt
[Musik]
das fleischtöpfe ich jetzt ein bisschen
ab und nehmen natürlich auch die kräuter
weg
[Musik]
die beute kann man übrigens ausspülen
und wiederverwenden und da ist auch ganz
wichtig dass es wirklich gute beutel
sind ohne weichmacher
denn die lebensmittel sind im kontakt
mit dem beutel und da ist gut eine gute
qualität zu verwenden
[Musik]
jetzt ist die panne gut erhitzt und
jetzt kann ich das fleisch nehmen und
schön kompakt hier rein legen mit slips
von beiden seiten etwa zwei minuten ganz
heiß angebraten und so entstehen jetzt
beim anbraten die röstaromen
[Musik]
hab ich noch zum abschrecken ein stück
zucker und aromen sind zweige mit sein
und kann zusammen gleich vom herd
herunternehmen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich aus der pfanne
herausgibt auf dem teller damit nicht
weitergeht
und jetzt muss ich das steak aber noch
mal ein paar minuten ruhen lassen etwa
fünf minuten damit sich der fleischsaft
schüler verteilt kompletten fleisch
immer kann muss gleich anrichten und ich
kann ihn derzeit schon mal meinen salat
den ich ihn vorbereitet habe mit dem
dressing vermischen und das
kartoffelgratin aus dem ofen holen
[Musik]
jetzt hatte ich das fleisch ruhen lassen
und habe dafür auch abgedeckt soll
und jetzt kann das aufschneiden jetzt
ist nur ganz wichtig dass er entgegen
der fahrrichtung schneidet das fleisch
zu vorschlägen quer und dann in die
richtung schneiden hat man nämlich die
kurzen fasern und dann ist auch richtig
schön zart usv was beobachter beachten
krieg immer eine rechnung über rechts
und frauen oben neuen videos ich merke
ich bei mir hat er sein was für ein
hammer messer
[Musik]
morath wissel salat muss sein erst jetzt
salaten muss sein das ist auch sehr sehr
schnell gemacht es ist was ganz
besonderes zu bieten ist aber ganzen
zutaten jetzt kartoffelsalat und dieses
wahnsinnige fleisch echter wahnsinn das
echt schön
[Musik]
drei stücke frei warum sind hier bitte
lieber hier hast du aber mathe ich hab
gar nicht gewusst was so und ich habe es
auch vor dem garen nicht gewürzt damit
sich einfach der eigengeschmack des
fleisches nicht verändert deswegen gibt
es erst schönes meersalz obendrauf
es reicht ein bisschen frisch gemahlener
pfeffer und immer frisch gemahlen haben
die marvel kaufen 5
richtig schön sprichworte sie zu
versichern
das ist ja mal das ist jetzt mal einen
karton weil ich weiß ich also wie gesagt
für das fest ist es genial sich
gigantisch alles sieht schon aus ist das
ist wirklich wo mein gott ist zur
feldmesse du brauchst kein messer merkt
wobei ihr okay alles probiert mal im
wahnsinn und mich nochmal ich würde ich
nochmal vor außen kross schön angebrannt
angebrannt nicht angebaut fallen
gebraten angebracht
darum richtig tolle röstaromen das
fleisch richtig schön zart und es ist ja
wirklich nicht schwer zu machen also im
prinzip braucht man mir gesagt entweder
die kennwort mit beheizbarem
rührschüssel oder kitchenaid geht es ja
auch mit der beheizbaren rührschüssel
oder einfach ein anderes gerät was eben
temperatur mit dabei hat die man eben
grad genau bestimmen kann jedermann
sowie ganz einfach zu man braucht wie
wäre es zu machen genau das klappt wäre
das erst mal lernt man sieht wie das
funktioniert und wie es dann macht mich
selber entscheiden den kartoffelsalat
hatte liegt ist will das sieht hübsch
aus den schildchen
achtung sich heißt also ihr müsst euren
gästen auch sagen dass die gusseisernen
pfanne sehr heiß sind ein traum was dort
wirklich da jetzt auch noch in die
kamera
drei kameras auf sich gerichtet im
bereich optisch aus nur hier auch zur
richtig cool mit mir das jetzt die
oberfläche oberfläche okay aber ist auch
richtig toll gewürzt ich lieb dich nun
mag dass wir über das wirklich richtig
schön witzig dann ist es einfach den
salat dazu der salat da tut es nochmal
müssen hunde setzt das ganze gewürzt mit
ich toll
falls jetzt auch noch dieses rezept
bekommen habt dann geht auf sallys -
blog.de da stets noch mal ganz genau da
stehen auch noch mal die ganzen tipps
die ich heute im video erwähnt habe
und weil schwarz ich würd sagen die
personen die dieses menü als erstes
zubereitet und uns ein foto schickt auf
facebook und auf instagram bekommt
einfach anfangen weil dies sei sein und
kann dann erst jetzt
die sind alle sind von horaz gesprochen
doch zafira set ich finde die auch von
hübschen von schön dann ist das ein
vorzeitiges weihnachtsgeschenk von uns
an euch ja das machen wir erstmal selber
und koch das ding jetzt macht amazon
bild machen morath okay also viel spaß
beim nachmachen und ich hoffe dass ich
das rezept gefallen hat und dass ihr ein
bisschen was lernen konnte also bis zum
nächsten mal tschüss machst du
[Musik]